chaque matin une alarme revêtir de mes
rêves
généralement elle cherchait une façon de
les teindre le plus rapidement possible
mais je réussis une fois sur deux par
contiendra une langue que je réussis
jamais à éteindre mais c'est celle qui
me rappelle que nous sommes en pleine
crise climatique
il ya quelques années je suis
pratiquement tombé en bas de ma chaise
en lisant un article publié dans une des
plus grandes revues médicales au monde
je l' ai même lu plusieurs fois pour
être certain de ce que je voyais et noir
sur blanc on concluait avec force que
les changements climatiques était la
plus grande menace à la santé du 21e
siècle
la plus grande menace et je me rappelle
très bien mais dit pourquoi mais
pourquoi c'est pas partout à la une de
tous les journaux dans nos écoles parce
que l'environnement
c'est important pour moi je me
considérais comme un forme et je savais
que les ours polaires allait pas très
bien que les coraux est en mauvais état
qu'on pollue et les océans etc on
détruisait les forêts mais personne
personne m'avait dit que les changements
climatiques étaient en train de
compromettre tous les progrès en santé
des dernières décennies
je rentrais en médecine par ce qui est
bon pour être complètement honnête j'ai
aucune idée dans quoi je m'embarquais
mais j'ai postulé avec la ferme
conviction qu'un état de bonne santé
autant physique que psychologique
c'est la clé pour que chaque individu
puisse se réaliser pleinement et ce bain
à toutes les étapes de notre vie de nos
premiers pas à nos dernier souffle je
voulais contribuer à ce que tous et tout
peut se faire vivre leur rêve et c'est
par la voix de la médecine que j'ai
choisi de le faire à travers les
milliers de pages que j'ai mémorisé pour
les examens et les stages cliniques les
discussions avec les collègues et les
tasses de café parfois très tard le soir
on a tenté le plus possible au cours de
ma formation comme mécène famille de me
préparer à traiter et à prévenir des
maladies à offrir des médicaments phares
de demander des examens à prendre soin d
un
mais aujourd'hui je suis à face à un
certain xylem parce que les changements
climatiques sont en train de nous rendre
malade très malade et chez pertinemment
que c'est pendant les quatre murs de ma
clinique que je vais être capable de
réduire ce risque
aucune opération aucune pilule ne pourra
magiquement nous sauver des changements
climatiques
si je vous découvre une grave maladie
mais je vous en parle pas vous en
voudriez 1
et bien pour moi la même question se
pose face au changement climatique
c'est pas un diagnostic que je peux
simplement écarté oublier ces mêmes liés
à quelque chose quitte à l'essence même
la profession médicale le sens de la
responsabilité sociale lorsqu'on devient
médecin auprès ferment je remplirai mais
de voir des médecins envers tous les
patients avec conscience loyauté
intégrité et aujourd'hui pour honorer
sincèrement j pas d'autre choix que
d'avoir un plan de traitement face à la
crise climatique un plan de traitement
qui politique qui est sociétale et qui
implique des gens qui ne sont même pas
dans le domaine de la santé
ça complique un peu les choses mais je
pense que c'est le moment qui nous ayons
une discussion éclairée sur les
changements climatiques et notre santé
imaginez vous que vous venez de rentrer
dans mon bureau de médecin
vous avez passé des examens j'ai les
résultats vous vous doutez quelque chose
qui cloche moi je sais pertinemment que
la discussion qui s'en vient sera pas
facile mais consomment il ya peut-être
moyen de s'en sortir
au moment où on se parle à travers le
monde
l'environnement est responsable d'un
décès sur quatre les changements
climatiques viennent s'ajouter à stains
faut les voir un peu comme des
amplificateurs de risque ils sont en
train de modifier tous les facteurs qui
influencent directement et indirectement
notre santé l'air que nous respirons la
qualité de l'eau que nous buvons la
nourriture à laquelle nous avons axé nos
ressources financières le sentiment de
sécurité
les endroits mêmes où on décide de vivre
je vous amène à montréal
la ville où j'habite à l'été 2010 8
montréal a été le théâtre d'une brûlante
canicule 66 personnes en sont décédées
vous faites peut-être partie des plus
chanceux ils ont été incommodés quelques
jours qu'ils ont et la misère à dormir
mais qui ont pas eu besoin d'être
hospitalisé pendant des longues semaines
parce que vous savez quand il fait chaud
le coeur peut avoir beaucoup de misère à
s'adapter à ce stress supplémentaire
d'autant plus quand on est assez âgée
qu'on à certains problèmes de santé
mentale ou qu'on vit dans un quartier où
le béton est roi et que les arbres sont
plutôt rares avec les changements
climatiques les vagues de chaleur vont
devenir de plus en plus chaude de plus
en plus longues
ils vont arriver de plus en plus souvent
seulement au québec on estime qu elles
causeront la mort de vingt mille
personnes
si les 50 prochaines années moi je
refuse d'apprendre à normaliser ses
idées celles qui peuvent être évités les
changements climatiques partage aussi
beaucoup avec la pollution de l'air
c'est pas très compliqué la pollution
c'est toxique pour à peu près tous les
organes et toutes les parties du corps
le coeur les poumons le cerveau le
placenta les vaisseaux sanguins et même
les yeux au canada un pays où on se
vante constamment de notre belle qualité
de l'air la pollution atmosphérique du
quinze mille personnes écoutent 120
milliards à chaque année ce qui rend les
énergies fossiles doublement meurtrière
mais les changements climatiques c'est
beaucoup plus que la chaleur extrême et
la pollution de l'air
c'est les inondations les feux de forêt
les ouragans qui détruisent nos maisons
parfois même les hôpitaux et qui nous
force à nous déplacer
ce sont des allergies qui vont durer
plus longtemps qui vont arriver plus tôt
ce sont des nouvelles maladies
infectieuses transmises par des petites
baies bienne qui ont un plaisir fou à
découvrir de nouveaux territoires il
leur fait bon vivre
ce sont même peut-être des nouvelles
pandémies ravageuse
ce sont nous sommes
doublée d'une exploitation intensive qui
peinent de plus en plus à nous nourrir
c'est un climat social d'incertitude de
stress de parts de deuil je pourrais
continuer de vous abreuver statistiques
effarantes parce qu'ils croyaient - il y
en a des tonnes jean-yves pratiquement
tous les jours mais je pense qu'à ce
point ci dans nos discussions
vous avez compris l'essentiel vous
partagez ce diagnostic je vous la donne
mais ça fait un peu peur parce que parce
que c'est le mien aussi je le partage
avec vous on a détruit un environnement
pour en reconstruire un qui tendrait
nous détruire à petit à grand feu on est
face à une urgence médicale
et puis comme on apprend mais film face
à une urgence
qu'est ce qu'on fait on traite le plus
rapidement possible et au meilleur de
nos connaissances parce que les sports
de la guérison
il est précisément alors le traitement
je vous propose aujourd'hui et et en
deux temps d'abord qu'on pense aux
changements climatiques
pensons à notre santé et ensuite mais
quand compass ou d'actions qui sont
bonnes sont bonnes pour le climat
parlons d'actions qui sont bonnes pour
notre santé y'a pas si longtemps et des
experts ont reconnu en fait les
changements climatiques comme étant la
plus grande opportunité d'améliorer la
santé tout le monde partout sur la
planète
pourquoi parce que l'action climatique
c'est bon pour la santé l'action
climatique c'est bon pour la santé parce
que ça améliore la qualité de l'air
qu'on respire en diminuant la quantité
de substances polluantes qui rentre dans
nos poumons à tous les jours l'action
climatique c'est bon pour la santé parce
que ça nous permet de repenser notre
alimentation faire plus de place aux
végétaux moins à la viande rouge sans
courage même nos producteurs locaux
l'action climatique si bon pour la santé
parce que ça nous permet de s'offrir
plus de ce passe dans nos milieux de vie
pour bouger pour courrier pour marcher
pour faire du vélo en donnant moins
d'espacé aux gros véhicules qui polluent
et au béton et l'action climatique ça
protège notre santé parce que ça te
protège la nature
elise avons ces immenses pouvoirs de
la température ambiante de diminuer la
pollution atmosphérique et même de nous
rendre plus heureux
récemment une équipe de chercheurs a
essayé de quantifier ça représentait
quoi ce potentiel de vies sauvées si les
pires eux aussi d'ambition climatique
qui respectaient l'accord de paris d'ici
ils ont regardé neuf pays ce qui
représente 50 % de la population
mondiale et 70% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre 5e et les gros joueurs la
chine l'un des états unis ces six pays
la rehausser nos ambitions climatiques
et prioriser la santé oms pourrait
sauver 1,6 million de vies avec une
meilleure qualité de l'air 6,4 millions
de vies avec une meilleure alimentation
et 2,1 millions de vis par une meilleure
activité physique et ce à chaque année
ce qui est étonnant c'est que ces
impacts l'heure les liens entre la santé
des changements climatiques sont souvent
oubliés on les calcule pas on les
intègre pas dans les analyses
financières mais pourtant ça se mesure
très bien moins de journées de travail
manquer - séjour chez le médecin moins
de médicaments ce qui étonnant aussi
c'est que quand les comptes c'est un pas
clos mais on se rend compte que l'action
climatique
ça rapporte ces mêmes rentable avec un
vraiment bon taux de rendement d'un seul
que vous aimeriez vraiment que la banque
vous le propose à l'échelle
internationale ça pourrait représenter
des trillions de dollars et parier à
chaque année alors on fait quoi
mais quand on pense au changement
climatique on pense à notre santé mais
après on en parle
pourquoi parce que le choix des mots la
façon dont on parle des changements
climatiques ça influence directement
notre motivation agir et les choix
politiques qui en découlent
la littérature sur la communication
climatiques et est fascinante mais a
fait un peu défaut parce que très peu
d'études ont regardé spécifiquement
l'impact d'un choix de nos portant sur
la santé mais pourtant celle qu'ils font
on arrive à une conclusion étrangement
similaires il existe un potentiel non
exploité alliés changement climatique
et santé et même à utiliser les
professionnels de la santé comme
messager de confiance la santé réussir
est mieux que l'économie ou
l'environnement générer un degré plus
fort d'action climatique de volonté
d'âgés et ce même chez les gens qui ne
se sentent pas concernés
vous savez je l' ai vécu il ya quelques
années j'étais à lima au pérou dans une
grande rencontre internationale sur le
climat l'année tout juste avant paris je
représentais un million d'étudiants et
étudiantes en médecine et j'avais mon
mandat de voir comment qu'on pourrait
intégrer la santé haskell et devenir
l'accord de paris
parce que à ce moment là dans la version
du texte qui circulait la santé était
mentionné nulle part en quelques jours
on ne réussit à convaincre cinq états
membres dont certains plutôt
conservateur a intégré mot pour mot
notre proposition à l'accord de paris
qui aujourd'hui l'article 109 et qui se
lit comme suit reconnaît l'intérêt
social économique et environnemental des
mesures d'atténuation volontaires et
leurs retombées bénéfiques sur
l'adaptation la santé et le
développement durable
à chaque fois tu repenses ça donne des
frissons de savoir que trois quatre
étudiants en médecine ont eu s'était pas
clair à ce moment là mais ça me
confirmer que le traitement il
fonctionnait que c'était le bon
finalement quand on la cherche un peu on
se rend compte que la santé elle est
partout elle nous permet enfin de voir
les engagements climatiques comme des
véritables opportunités comme une
opportunité de créer quelque chose de
beau tout le monde ensemble notre
consultation médicale tire à sa fin
c'est difficile de prédire avec
précision comment notre maladie
climatiques vont évoluer mais je le vois
un peu comme si j'étais dans une salle
d'urgence puis qu'un passant devant moi
faisons un arrêt cardiaque
j'ai des décisions critiques à prendre
mais je dois le faire rapidement parce
qu'après tout j'ai une vie à sauver
collectivement on est un peu dans cette
situation là les scientifiques nous
disent que les dix prochaines années
seront cruciales que c'est en prend des
bonnes
et de le faire maintenant mais comme je
sais que c'est possible de réussir la
transition énergétique
je sais que c'est possible de sauver des
millions de vie partout sur la planète
et dont la nôtre alors au coeur de ce
traitement
d'abord qu'on pense aux changements
climatiques
pensons à notre santé à celle de nos
parents à celle de nos enfants
et lorsqu'on parle d'action qui sont
bonnes pour le climat parlons d'actions
qui sont bonnes pour notre santé
maintenant quand la larme seul le matin
pour me réveiller je pense à tout ce qui
est possible de faire à ce traitement
climatique qui fonctionne qui est à
notre portée kit accessible et
maintenant la larme je la trouve
beaucoup plus agréable merci
[Applaudissements]